DIFFERENT FORM, IT COULD BE WITH
CANADA, WITH MEXICO.
ONE-ON-ONE, AND, A MUCH SIMPLER
AGREEMENT.
>> GOOD EVENING.
EVEN BEFORE LEAVING THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT RAISE
A FEW EYEBROWS AROUND THE GLOBE
BY SUGGESTING RUSSIA SHOULD BE
HERE TAKING PART IN THE TALKS.
JUST THE LATEST REMINDER OF HIS
UNCONVENTIONAL STYLE, AND TO
SOME OF HIS IMPRUDENT RATE
APPROACH GLOBAL POLITICS.
>> COME I CAN SPEAK TO WHETHER
YOU LIKE IT OR NOT, AND WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S POLITICALLY
CORRECT, WE HAVE A WORLD TO RUN.
AND OF THE G7, WHICH USED TO BE
G8, THROUGH RUSH OUT.
THEY SHOULD LET RUSSIA COME BACK
AGAIN BECAUSE WE SHOULD HAVE
RUSSIA AT THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
>> IT WAS QUINTESSENTIAL TRUMP.
IT REVERBERATED ACROSS THE GLOBE
AND CAROMED ACROSS THE PARTISAN
POLITICAL DIVIDE HERE AT HOME.
>> President Trump: WHY ARE WE
HAVING A MEETING WITHOUT RUSSIA
BEING IN THE MEETING?
I WOULD RECOMMEND, AND IT'S UP
TO THEM, BUT RUSSIA SHOULD BE IN
THE MEETING.
>> Reporter: RUSSIA WAS KICKED
OUT OF THE G8 BECAUSE IT INVADED
UKRAINE, AND ANNEXED CRIMEA.
THE PRESIDENT SENTIMENT LET
RUSSIA SHOULD BE PART OF THE
GATHERING IN QUEBEC CLEARLY AT
ODDS WITH MANY IN HIS OWN PARTY
AND KEY ALLIES FROM AROUND THE
WORLD, INCLUDING THE U.K. WHICH
REALLY DON'T LIKE IT WEIGHED IN
WITH THE STATEMENT THAT READ, IN
PART, THE PRIME MINISTER'S HAS
ALWAYS SAID WE SHOULD ENGAGE
WITH RUSSIA BUT BEWARE.
WE HAVE SEEN THE LINE FROM
RUSSIA IN A VARIETY OF WAYS.
BEFORE ANY CONVERSATIONS COULD
TAKE PLACE ABOUT RUSSIA
REJOINING, IT NEEDS TO CHANGE
ITS APPROACH.
ONCE ON THE GROUND IN QUEBEC,
THE PRESIDENT STOOD WITH WORLD
LEADERS FOR THE TRADITIONAL
FAMILY PHOTO, THOUGH THE SMILE
SEEMED TO BELIE THE TENSION
BENEATH THE SURFACE.
JUST AHEAD OF THE CEMENT, THE
PRESIDENT RAGED ON TWITTER ABOUT
UNFAIR TRADE AND COME CALLING
OUT AMERICA'S AIR ALLIES FOR
THEIR STEEP TARIFFS ON AMERICAN
GOODS LIKE CANADA'S STEEP TARIFF
ON DAIRY.
HIS COUNTERPARTS FIRED BACK,
THREATENING TO GO IT ALONE IF
THE U.S. LAND MEMBERS WITH STEEP
TARIFFS.
>> Translator: THE
UNITED STATES ARE NATURALLY A
GREAT ECONOMIC POWER BUT IF THEY
CONTINUED TOWARDS A FORM OF
ISOLATIONISM, DISTANCING
THEMSELVES FROM THEIR OWN
HISTORY, FROM THEIR OWN VALUES,
FROM THE ROLE THEY PLAY IN
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS,
THAT WILL BE BAD FOR THE
>> Reporter: BY GOING IT ALONE
MIGHT BE DIFFICULT FOR THE REST
OF THE GROUP, CONSIDERING THE
U.S. GDP FOR 2018 IS EXPECTED TO
TOP $20 TRILLION.
THAT'S MORE THAN THE OTHER
MEMBERS COMBINED.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS COME FROM
THE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED TO
LEAVE THE SUMMIT HOURS EARLIER
THAN ORIGINALLY PLANNED TO MAKE
WAY FOR THE NORTH KOREAN SUMMIT
IN SINGAPORE.
A VISIT WHICH HAS STOKED
CONCERNS ON CAPITOL HILL THAT
THE PRESIDENT MIGHT TRY TO AND
RUN CONGRESS TO FORGE A DEAL IN
THE SAME MANNER THAT HIS
PREDECESSOR DID WITH THE IRAN
NUCLEAR ACCORD.
>> President Trump: I WOULDN'T
DO LIKE OBAMA DID.
YOU KNOW, HE TRIED TO GET IT
THROUGH, THE IRAN DEAL.
HE TRIED TO GET IT THROUGH
CONGRESS BUT FAILED SO HE JUST
DID IT WITHOUT.
>> Reporter: EARLIER THIS
EVENING, THE PRESIDENT SUGGESTED
THAT A JOINT STATEMENT WITH
CANADA ON TERRACE WAS STILL VERY
LIKELY AT THE CONCLUSION OF HIS